[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello thanks for watching so basically
those exercises I came up with today
because when I first started practicing
I could not play the Beethoven the
opening of the Beethoven sonata with the
double thirds and also the chopin etude
so I decided I would find ways to just
work on double thirds and no parallel
intervals in general and it just grew
from there
so if you're working on that I wish you
good luck because I know how hard it is
and how frustrating it is because a lot
of times it's almost like a tongue
twister cuz you feel like you can get it
it's pretty simple but once you try to
go a little faster or go for a little
longer then it just keeps getting worse
and worse and I think the key though is
to just work on not finger independence
cuz they they really depend on each
other when you're playing parallel
anything but using more of your fingers
rather than your wrists because I have
that problem especially with that etude
I used to use more of my wrist this
rotate rotation motion to get the thirds
from one third to the next but that only
creates problems because you're not
using the tips of your fingers which
will enable you to be more precise and
have more control so that's it thank you
so much again and I'll see you in the
next video bye
[Music]